[Musik]
weltraumforschung genau wie die nokia-
wissenschaft kennt kein gewissen
ob sie nun ein gutes oder schlechtes
bewirken
entscheidet der mensch nur wenn die
vereinigten staaten eine
vormachtstellung einnehmen können wir
entscheiden ob dieses weite meer ein
friedliches gewässer oder ein neuer
kriegsschauplatz wird
china führte in 800 kilometern höhe den
ersten anti satelliten waffentest an
einem alten wettersatelliten
nach drei fehlschüssen gelang es china
einen ihrer eigenen alten
wettersatelliten abwischen
der test könnte teil des chinesischen
versuch seine militärpräsenz im weltraum
einzurichten sind die spionagesatelliten
der usa in gefahr
nach dem abschuss haben sie eine wolke
weltraumschrott zurückgelassen
es macht uns angreifbar kann ums leben
[Applaus]
es gibt länder die uns gegenüber
feindlich sind auch im weltraum die
gefahr für die weltraum sicherheit ist
real
sicherheit im weltraum ist von
entscheidender bedeutung verlust könnte
unsere nation
trifft es kommerzielle satelliten könnte
so ein angriff us firmen und die
industrie lehne
china warnt davor dass ein krieg im
weltraum alle erdbewohner treffen würden
der weltraum wird immer voller wir
brauchen verteidigungsmechanismen ein
weltraum waffen verbotes gescheitert ein
weltraum krieg nicht auszuschließen
der weltraum ist das rückgrat unserer
sicherheit es gibt keine alternative
wir müssen den weltraum militärisch
beherrschen diese überzeugung soll uns
die nächsten 50 jahre lang
[Applaus]
die
[Musik]
in der mitte des zwanzigsten
jahrhunderts schoss die menschheit ihren
ersten satelliten ins all und er schloss
so einen neuen kriegsschauplatz
[Musik]
noch ist der weltraum eine friedliche
zuflucht doch das dominanzstreben der
menschheit könnte die weiter um unsere
welt wie auch die welt an sich vorher
wen können wir unseren himmel
anvertrauen
[Musik]
kaiser augustus kam 27 jahre vor christi
geburt an die macht
unter kaiser augustus
lebten die römer besser als in allen
vorangegangenen reichen der welt
nur bessere straßen keine tierarten die
die schifffahrt bedroht
das leben war zu der zeit so gut
dass sie einen namen erhielt
bis heute spricht man von der pax romana
dem römischen friedens
auch eine andere periode des friedens
hat einen namen erlangt pax americana
der amerikanische frieden
[Musik]
sie bezeichnet die periode in der der
einfluss der usa relativ friedliche
bedingungen erschaffen hat
heute scheint die pax americana in
gefahr
die meisten von uns empfinden nur
frieden wenn wir uns nicht im krieg
befinden doch frieden bedeutet auch die
präsenz eines leibhaftigen herrn in
unserem leben auch
wenn wir jeden morgen auf einem
schlachtfeld erwachen der herrgott nimmt
uns nicht aus dem finsteren tal heraus
sondern weist uns den weg hindurch
so steht es in jesaja 54 denn es sollen
wohl berge weichen und hügel hinfallen
aber meine gnade sollen nicht von die
reichen und der bund meines friedens
nicht hinfallen
[Musik]
ich bin cool tadelt erster klasse an der
airforce akademie ich mache in 44 tagen
meinen abschluss und hoffe dass ich
allen helfen kann ihre freiheiten
auszulegen
[Musik]
nein
pax americana ist die politische ansicht
dass amerika aufgrund seiner stellung
als einzige supermacht nicht nur die
möglichkeit sondern auch die
verantwortung hat den weltfrieden bis in
die ferne zukunft
unser land war schon immer eine
schlüsselfigur für den weltfrieden
diese verantwortung reicht jetzt bis in
den himmel hinauf
länder wie china nun im weltraum
angreifen führt das zu einer ernsthaften
krise
hoffentlich können wir mit ihnen darüber
reden bevor es hässlich wird
die usa und ihre geheimdienste machen
sich sorgen es könnte einen angriff auf
die vereinigten staaten geben
nicht mit atomwaffen nicht mit chemie
oder bio waffe sondern technologisch
globale kommunikation ist ein normaler
teil unseres alltags
meilenweit über uns weit ab unseres
bewusstseins verwalten satelliten unsere
verbundene gesellschaft
beim weltraum denkt man oft an das
hubble teleskop oder mars sonde
man denkt nicht daran dass man den
weltraum jeden tag nutzt
[Musik]
wenn man mit dem handy telefoniert
mietek man wenn man geld am automaten
abhebt
satelliten sorgen für fernsehen und
nachrichten aus aller welt
jedes navigationssystem nutzt sie ob zu
lande auf dem wasser in der luft oder im
eigenen auto
ohne satelliten gäbe ist keine wetter-
und katastrophen vorher sorge
unser ganzes leben hängt von satelliten
ab das wird uns allerdings erst bewusst
wenn wir sie verlieren
aktuell umkreisen mindestens 1000 aktive
satelliten die die erde
sie gehören 45 nationen
der großteil der welt nutzt ihre signale
die usa sind die dominante kraft bei
weltraum systemen sowohl im zivilen als
auch im militärischen bereich
echtzeit schlachtfeld verwaltung mit
bomben treffern darum geht es das können
wir mittlerweile im weltall in der luft
auf dem land wie zu wasser leisten und
miteinander koordinieren wir arbeiten
seit der satz dann daran und verfeinern
es mit jedem konflikt weiter wir werden
immer besser darin
seit dem ersten golfkrieg ist der
weltraum ein schlüssel stück
amerikanischer militäroperationen
beim luftangriff auf bagdad im irak
krieg lenkten die usa 71 prozent ihrer
raketen
der weltraum ist das rückgrat der
militärmacht amerikas oder vielleicht
doch die achillesferse
überraschungsangriff im weltall ist der
ultimative albtraum
wenn sie 50 us satelliten ausschalten
könnte china das us-militär völlig lähme
die
kommunikation mit den streitkräften
breche zusammen die ob chronischen
satelliten der us geheimdienste zur
erkennung militärischer bewegungen auf
der ganzen welt würden ausfallen
und auch die präzisions leitsysteme
moderner satellitengesteuerte lenkwaffen
würden ausfallen
ein elektronisches pearl harbor
ohne den weltraum wäre die usa nicht
imstande jegliche militärische
operationen durchzuführen
[Musik]
es hängt viel davon ab dass die usa ihre
weltraum anlagen vor angriffen anderer
schützen und weiter nutzen können
und falls nötig anderen die verwendung
derartiger mittel zu verwehren
[Musik]
die welt verändert sich mehr und mehr
länder erobern den weltraum eine raum
schlacht ist nicht mehr nur science
fiction
die neue welt verlangt neue lösungen das
ist das neue us air force space command
das elitekommando ist amerikas adlerauge
und bewacht unsere interessen von ganz
oben
[Musik]
waffeneinsatz vom all auf dem boden wenn
china erkennt dass die militärische
macht der usa völlig vom weltall abhängt
die usa werden die weltpolizei sein
spricht sie dieser titel irgendwie an
ist das so richtig
was folgt daraus
eine der ersten aufgaben der us marine
war die bekämpfung der piraterie
da nun der handel vom weltall abhängt
ist die sicherung von recht und ordnung
dort eine bedeutsame aufgabe
mehr und mehr länder nutzen den weltraum
für ihre sicherheit
konflikte sind unvermeidbar krieg im
weltraum wird wohl oder übel komm adobe
hat die gleiche militär ethik die auf
der erde gilt wird auch im weltraum geld
man kann jede analogie übertreiben aber
die parallele von weltraum- und seefahrt
ist durchaus hilfreich
[Applaus]
holland kontrollierte die sie im 17
jahrhundert
wie auch england im 18 19 jahrhundert
die meere beherrscht so tun es die usa
im 20 und 21 jahrhundert
zum schutz des handels und zur
bekämpfung der piraterie
das gleiche können wir im weltraum
leiste zum wohle aller wie auch zum
wohle von uns selbst den himmel
überwachen
buchstabieren sie den namen ihres chefs
wenn wir hunderte bewaffnete
kriegsschiffe auf die meere entsenden
beschwert sich so gut wie niemand wir
würden die mehrere waffen denn sie alle
wissen dass unsere waffen den freien
verkehr für alle garantieren die
friedliche interessen verfolgen
in gleicher weise könnten weltraum
systeme der usa allen schutz bieten
die us airforce wurde beauftragt den
zugang zum weltraum zu sichern oder im
konfliktfall zu verweigern ist
die airforce ohne waffen dazu imstande
was ist eine weltraum waffe
was wissen wir über die fähigkeiten der
usa zum schutz des himmels und zur
zugangskontrolle
der feier wurde bisher hauptsächlich für
forschung bei der satelliten verfolgung
genutzt auch die astronomie profitierte
von der leser entfernungsmessung mit der
man sterne genauer orten und die
entfernung bestimmen konnte
die haushalts dokumente der airforce
erwähnen auch die nutzung von starfire
als anti satelliten waffe
[Musik]
die akkus bestritt im kongress gegenüber
sämtliche ambitionen starfire als anti
satelliten waffe zu nutzen
sie treffen jedoch die möglichkeit den
laserstrahl sehr fein zu bündeln und
stabil zu halten
dabei zielen sie auf einen satelliten
[Musik]
bei der verfolgung von satelliten
braucht man keinen gebündelten
laserstrahl man braucht einen weiten
damit das ziel im sichtfeld bleibt
[Musik]
viele von uns machen sich sorgen es
könnte sich um einen geplanten test
einer anti satelliten waffe handeln
[Musik]
im april 2005
startete die air force den
experimentellen satelliten access
dieser mikro satellit ist theoretisch in
der lage
satelliten anderer länder zu stören
ist es geschehen ein ist es möglich
prinzipiell ja
in wirklichkeit
wer weiß
[Musik]
man muss sich im klaren sein dass alle
technologie die im weltraum zum einsatz
kommt ebenso für die kriegsführung
verwendet werden kann wie für harmlose
zwecke
laser für die genauere verfolgung gute
idee
mikro satelliten die größere umkreisen
und bilder machen können gute idee so
findet man heraus was mit dem satelliten
nicht stimmt was aktuell schwierig ist
dieser kleine micro satellit könnte aber
auch zu einem fremden satelliten
geschickt werden um ihn zu rammen und zu
zerstören
technologie weiß nicht ob sie eine waffe
ist oder einen harmlosen nutzen hat
es kommt auf die intentionen derjenigen
an die die systeme bauen
[Musik]
wie können wir friedliche oder
feindselige ziele von systemen im
weltraum erkennen
hat die aufrüstung des weltalls
vielleicht schon begonnen kann
[Musik]
ich leite die astronautik abteilung hier
an der airforce akademie wir lehren
unsere kadetten die grundlagen der
astronautik
fast alle der knapp 40.000 absolventen
der akademie haben mindestens einen kurs
in unserer abteilung gesucht
wie heißt der bereich hier bog stoßwelle
genau darüber haben wir einen stark
elliptische norbert
militär strategie lehrt uns dass man das
schlachtfeld nur kontrollieren kann wenn
man die überlegene position einnimmt ob
nun zu lande auf dem wasser in der luft
oder im all wer das kontrolliert ist im
vorteil den gegner hiervon aussperren zu
können ist ein riesiger vorteil
[Applaus]
[Musik]
streitkräfte setzen seit jeher auf
überlegene technologie um einen vorteil
zu bekommen
im amerikanischen bürgerkrieg nutzten
die truppen insbesondere das unions her
heißluftballons um über die bäume hinweg
gegner zu erstehen
auch früher flugzeuge im ersten
weltkrieg waren aufklärungs maschinen
die im flug gegnerische positionen
finden seiten
[Musik]
der weltraum gilt nun als die ultimative
vorteils position die nation die den
weltraum für sich beanspruchen kann hat
den gleichen positions- vorteil den
zuvor hügel berge oder auch der luftraum
bot
sechster september 1944 beladen mit
einer tonne sprengstoff wird die erste
taktische rakete der wehrmacht die v2
oder vergeltungswaffe auf london
abgefeuert
[Musik]
unter hitlers armee war mit der v2
wegweisend
die vergeltungswaffe war das erste von
menschenhand gebaute objekt im weltall
auf dem weg zu zielen in europa
[Applaus]
die rakete wurde im dritten reich
entwickelt und von den nazis eingesetzt
gegen ende des zweiten weltkriegs befand
sich das programm unter der kontrolle
der ss um sicherzugehen dass es auch
realisiert wurde
die arbeiter für das programm wurden aus
konzentrationslagern beordert das lager
mittelbau-dora war eines der
fürchterlichsten der fall
[Musik]
ein junger ss offizier namens wernher
von braun war der leitende ingenieur bei
entwicklung und bau der 2 die erste
ballistische rakete erregte das
interesse reiche geldgeber jenseits des
dritten reichs
[Musik]
technologisch war die v2 damals bahn
rechnet sowohl westlicher als auch
östlicher kräfte waren interessiert
[Musik]
von braun und 100 seiner besten
ingenieure wurden im rahmen der
geheimoperationen paperc lebt in die usa
geschafft
das pentagon beauftragte von brown und
sein team mit der entwicklung einer
verbesserten v2
von braun leitete die entwicklung von
redstone der ersten amerikanischen
ballistischen rakete so erlangt der
großen militärischen und
wissenschaftlichen einfluss wernher von
braun wurde stellvertretender direktor
der nasa
die ehemaligen nazi wissenschaftler
arbeiteten als kollaborateure für das
us-militär
bei der erschließung des weltalls als
kriegsschauplatz
hermann bitte setzen sie sich die
konferenz beginnt
unser gast rené heute ist dr wernher von
braun
die eroberung des weltalls ist die
größte technologische herausforderung
unserer zeit
auf der rechten seite dieses bildes
sehen sie eine große reifen förmige
raumstation die sowohl im zivilen als
auch im militärischen bereich grosses
aufklärungs potenzial bietet
ihm hat sie raumfahrt wissenschaftler
die mit operation paper clip in die usa
kamen entwickelten pläne die welt vom
all aus mithilfe weltraum basierter
waffen zu beherrschen
es erscheint möglich eine solche
plattform im weltraum als basis für das
bombardement von zielen am boden zu
nutzen
meiner meinung nach könnte ein solches
bombardement eine nie dagewesene
präzision erlauben
anfangs begegnete man den deutschen
wissenschaftlern mit vielen misstrauen
dabei schon bald erhielten sie alle die
amerikanische staatsbürgerschaft
sie spielten eine entscheidende rolle
auf dem weg der usa ins weltraum
zeitalter
dank der entwicklung des saturn raketen
projekts von brauns
am vierten oktober
1957 schockierte russland die freie welt
die udssr schoss den ersten satelliten
in die umlaufbahn
sputnik 1
dies zementierte die sowjetische führung
beim wettlauf im all wir sollen einen
wissenschaftlichen satelliten starten
ich habe der armee leitung versprochen
dass wir höchstens 90 tage brauchen
werden
[Musik]
wernher von braun hielt die 90 tage
frist ein
seine modifizierte v2 schoss den ersten
us satelliten in eine umlaufbahn
der wettlauf ins all begann der lang
ersehnte tages da die usa verfügen über
einen weltraum satelliten
[Musik]
welches recht gilt in diesem neuen
bereich
ich kam 1958 zum diplomatischen dienst
amerikas und wurde dem un politbüro zu
ich war mit 22 jahren der erste beamte
des außenministeriums im auslandseinsatz
sie sagten kümmere dich doch um die
multilateralen aspekte unseres
weltraumprogramms wir schickten gerade
unseren ersten satelliten ins all und
plötzlich war ich verantwortlich
ich sagte das wäre verrückt ich bin
jetzt 22
sie erwiderten das ist ein job
seit heute ist der weltraum frei
unberührt von jedem konflikt
kein land hat hier ansprechen
so muss es bleiben
als sie anfingen war nichts festgelegt
wem gehört das weltall der mond der
masters war es wie damals als kolumbus
die neue welt entdeckte und anspruch auf
amerika
würden wir das können oder die russen
die andere frage war ob wir das weltall
friedlich nutzen würden
oder für aggression und militär business
wir brauchen neue konzepte
damit wir vielleicht in zehn jahren
menschen auf den mond schicken können um
eine wissenschaftliche oder militärische
basis zu errichten
wir fragten uns ob es nicht einen
bereich geben könnte der frei von waffen
bliebe
doch in bezug auf die friedliche nutzung
intervenierte das
verteidigungsministerium
sie sagten sie wären nicht bereit die
idee von waffen im weltall aufzugeben
wir verzichten auf
massenvernichtungswaffen im weltall
aber wir unterzeichnen keinen vertrag
der uns waffen im alter bietet
ich hatte verloren das aussenministerium
verlor gegen das
verteidigungsministerium
das weltraum abkommen von 1967 verbot
massenvernichtungswaffen im weltall aber
nicht waffen an sich
[Musik]
das verteidigungsministerium überzeugte
die staats und regierungschefs der welt
von der bewaffnung des weltalls
[Musik]
atomwaffen waren nun im weltall verboten
verbreiteten sich auf der erde jedoch
rasant
[Musik]
da nun beide seiten dieser geteilten
welt über unvorstellbare
zerstörungskraft verfügen erscheint die
gegenseitige vernichtung eine reale
möglichkeit für die zukunft der
menschheit
ärzte rieten haben an sich keine direkte
auswirkung auf die nationale sicherheit
verfügen gleichzeitig aber auch über
echte militärische signifikant
aus angst von nokian angriffen wollten
die udssr und die usa position und
schlagkraft der gegnerischen waffen
erfahren
beide entsandten satelliten um das
arsenal des gegners ständig zu
überwachen
der militärische wettstreit und die
ultimative vorteils position hatte
begonnen
die usa planten heimlich den nächsten
schritt zur bewaffnung des als anfang
der 1980 er jahre
am 12 juni 1982 gab es eine riesige
demoliert
fast eine million menschen protestierten
auf dem höhepunkt des kalten krieges
gegen atomwaffen
ich sah es im fernsehen anschließend
zeigten sie eine konferenz der
politischen rechten
der damalige anführer der strategic
defense initiative sdi
jemand fragte general graham ob er wegen
der demonstration besorgt sei es wären
schließlich eine million menschen
gekommen um gegen atomwaffen zu
protestieren er erwiderte das wäre doch
fantastisch sie protestieren draußen
gegen interkontinentalraketen und wir
sind auf dem weg ins all sie haben keine
ahnung lasst sie demonstrieren
was wäre wenn die strategische raketen
abfangen könnten noch bevor sie uns oder
unsere verbündeten erreichen das wird
noch jahre vielleicht jahrzehnte dauern
es wird fehlschläge geben aber auch
erfolge und durchbricht ist
jedoch nicht das ende der bedrohung
durch einen atomkrieg jeden preis wert
meine amerikanischen mitbürger heute
ergreifen wir schritte die die zukunft
der menschheit für immer verändern
könnten ich bitte um ihre gebete und
unterstützung
danke gute nacht als ich 1985 teil des
us comedy und services war war die
beaufsichtigung und untersuchung der
strategic defense initiative meine erste
aufgabe
das war ronald reagans star wars
programm
diese neue nationale strategie bricht
mit der politik garantiert gegenseitiger
vernichtung
ronald reagans star wars wäre das space
shuttle der waffenträger
wird ein sowjetischer abschluss entdeckt
starken amerikanische abfangsysteme als
erste stufe der verteidigung
orbitale waffen batterien würden atom
schläge vereiteln noch bevor sie den us
luftraum erreichen
[Musik]
wir dachten es würde funktionieren dass
die technologie in griffweite wäre und
dass das alles verändern würde mein
vorgesetzter sagte zu mir nicht nur
raketenabwehrsysteme sondern alle
größeren waffensysteme würden ins all
verlagert der weltraum war die neue
vorteils position und würde bis zum ende
des jahrhunderts zum austragungsort
aller militäroperationen werden
eine debatte galaktischen ausmaßes der
berühmteste stern forscher der nation
gegen den leiter von star wars im
pentagon es kann die bevölkerung nicht
schützen die sowjets können es
überwältigen überlisten und unterwandert
ich kann und will die vorstellung nicht
akzeptieren dass es nicht funktionieren
kann
die meisten pläne von star wars würden
öffentlichkeitswirksame animation and
leiden
das us-militär widmete sich jedoch auch
weiterhin star wars
als die usa zur alleinigen supermacht
wurden hielt das pentagon an weltraum
waffen gegen feindliche angriffe fest
star wars kehrte im einundzwanzigsten
jahrhundert unter neuem namen zurück
missile defense
wir brauchen einen neuen rahmen um eine
raketenabwehr gegen die bedrohungen der
modernen welt aufzubauen
ballistische raketenabwehr
wir müssen effektiver raketenabwehr
umsetzen
als george bush im jahr 2000 das amt
übernahm gab es für ihn und seinen
dunstkreis leute wie paul wolfowitz
donald rumsfeld und dick cheney nur zwei
priorität
zum einen saddam hussein loszuwerden und
zum anderen ein raketenabwehrsystem
guten morgen ich komme direkt von einem
treffen mit dem nationalen
sicherheitsrat
wir berieten über das was ich mit
wladimir putin in vielen gesprächen über
monate hinweg gesprochen hatte
da ist die usa vom abm vertrag von
1972 zurücktreten müssen
als george tabillion bush präsident
wurde gab der russland sofort zu
verstehen dass sich die usa in sechs
monaten aus dem abm vertrag zurückziehen
würden weil er die möglichkeit der usa
beschränkte weltraumtechnologie wie
satelliten abwehr und so genannte
raketenabwehrsysteme zu testen und
einzusetzen
das pentagon warnte heute dass das all
das schlachtfeld der zukunft sein würde
darin habe der weltraum nun oberste
priorität im pentagon
ein vier sterne general ist nun für das
air force space command und somit alle
militäraktivitäten im weltraum
einschließlich raketenabwehrsystemen
verantwortlich
wir werden unsere interessen im weltall
verteidigen und fördern
dies sei der erste schritt auf dem weg
waffen im weltraum zu postieren
[Applaus]
das budget sieht ausgaben in höhe von
8,3 milliarden dollar für raketenabwehr
programme vor
das sind mit zusätzlich 3 milliarden
dollar fast 60 prozent mehr als im
vergangenen jahr es ist viel geld aber
der präsident besteht darauf unsere
bevölkerung sowie die unserer
verbündeten und unsere truppen im
einsatz schützen zu können
[Musik]
ich habe einen raketenstart
raketenstart bestätigt zwei ziele
heute betreibt die airforce kriegsspiele
in denen sogenannte schurkenstaaten
amerikanische städte angreifen möglicher
einschlag in san francisco doch wer
würde die usa tatsächlich so angreifen
es ist schon interessant dass die
bedrohung kleiner wird anstatt zu
wachsen die bedrohung durch ballistische
raketen schrumpft es gibt viel weniger
von ihnen als noch vor 15 jahren
weniger nationen mit raketenprogrammen
insbesondere den usa feindlich gesonnene
staaten haben weniger solche programme
letztendlich machen wir uns nur wegen
der programme weniger staaten sorgen
nordkorea
sie haben aber nur mittelstreckenraketen
und können die usa nicht erreichen
seit ronald reagan stellte jeder
präsident ein budget für die
raketenabwehr zur verfügung
verschiedene bezeichnungen
verschiedene quer
insgesamt mindestens 200 milliarden
dollar
bekommen die steuerzahler einen
angemessenen gegenwert dafür
es ist betrug die raketenabwehr ist der
größte betrug im
verteidigungsministerium und da gibt es
viel konkurrenz
ich bin wirklich davon überzeugt
mit die raketenabwehr ist der
langwierigste betrug im
verteidigungsministerium
wenn ein raketen schlag so
unwahrscheinlich ist warum so viel für
die abwehr aus dem all ausgeben
ist die raketenabwehr eine tarnung für
weitergehende ziele nimmt
jedes system zur abwehr ballistischer
raketen kann satelliten angreifen wo
auch immer es ist
das ist unvermeidbar
eine ballistische rakete zu treffen ist
in gewisser weise schwieriger als einen
satelliten zu treffen daher sind
raketenabwehrsysteme eigentlich immer in
der lage satelliten anzuvisieren
im februar 2008 zerstörten die
vereinigten staaten einen defekten us
satelliten mithilfe des
raketenabwehrsystems
die usa zeigten dass die sogenannten
kill witters alle satelliten der unteren
erdumlaufbahn vernichten konnten
raketenabwehr ist ein trojanisches pferd
und hat nichts mit verteidigung zu tun
es geht um macht projektion im angriff
ich war in der basis in colorado springs
über dem eingang prangt dort
herr des weltalls ich habe ihre
dokumente gelesen die welschen twenty
twenty und viele weitere space command
dokumente seit jahren die us kontrolle
des alls propagieren wir würden den
weltraum beherrschen und anderen ländern
den zugang verweigert
dass unsere fünf prozent der
weltbevölkerung in den usa anderen
ländern den zugang zum all verweigern es
doch die größte provokation
wir sind im weltraum so dominant dass
mir jedes land das sich gegen uns stellt
leid und
die koordination unserer kräfte zu land
zu wasser und in der luft sowie die
kontrolle aller vorurteile ist
verheerend
amerika kann nun ein imperium der pax
americana errichten das jahrzehntelang
bestehen würden
eines der mittel dazu ist die starke
kontrolle des alls durch amerika
[Musik]
die bewaffnung des weltalls dient der
wirtschaft und kontrollsucht der usa sie
schützt innere interessen bis hin zu den
entlegensten grenzgebieten in bester
imperialer tradition
die geschichte lehrt uns dass länder wie
die usa anfangs eine armee aufbauen um
sich zu schützen
die vereinigten staaten brauchten eine
armee um sich vor der eingeborenen
bevölkerung zu schützen die wir durch
unsere expansion im gesamten
staatsgebiet vernichteten vor mexiko als
wir die hälfte ihres landes stellen
dafür und für interventionen brauchten
wir eine armee
dann brauchen länder auch noch die
marina
großbritannien nutzte seine marine um
sich gegen menschen in indien und afrika
zu verteidigen
sie beschrieben das aber recht ehrlich
und sagten die marine schütze
kommerzielle interessen und
investitionen
investment das gilt für uns genauso
jetzt gibt es eine neue grenzregion das
alles jetzt müssen wir das weltall
kontrollieren um kommerzielle interessen
und investitionen zu schützen
willkommen in der zukunft
[Musik]
der ort größere profite besserer
geschäfte sowie unglaubliche aussichten
und unaufhörlichen wachstums
einfach riesig
steuervorteile geschäftschancen profite
die größten fortune 500 firmen nutzen
sie bereits
ob man nun umziehen möchte expandieren
oder das bekannte universum mit seinem
kapitalistischen traum erobern bilden
sie helfen dabei
begrüßen sie mit mir general kevin
schiller
ich freue mich hier in colorado springs
zu sein und es passt auch genau
denn vor 25 jahren hielt ihr general
james harding als erster kommandant des
air force space command die fahne hoch
und sagte colorado springs würde das
militärische weltraum hauptquartier der
nation werden und so kam es auch
[Musik]
in colorado springs findet man sowohl
staatliches militär als auch private
militärunternehmen
sie machen fast ein drittel der
bevölkerung aus das ist schon erheblich
die industrie sagt jetzt wir machen
keine autos keine kleidung oder andere
waren mehr in amerika wir bauen waffen
[Musik]
das ist unser weltraum
überwachungssystem
die weiterentwicklung eines raketen
erkennungs satelliten
es kann raketen im flug erkennen
identifizieren und unterscheiden
wir finden sie jemand anders schießt sie
ab
wir arbeiten an den wichtigsten und
spektakulärsten technologien der welt
und wir sind die besten
der großteil der us wirtschaft leidet
unter der rezession
doch die bewaffnung des alls versorgt
florierende unternehmen mit aufträgen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
kibo
[Musik]
zu unserer rechten sehen wir eines der
neun unternehmen hier sae international
rasant wachsende firmen von denen noch
nie jemand gehört hatte wie every
communications
unbekannte namen aber dennoch sind sie
die neuen branchengrößen in der
militärindustrie
rechts die aerospace corporation
links
[Applaus]
hier drüben haben wir lockheed martin
und hier rechts ist northrop dran die
waren schon immer ein großes unternehmen
aber vor ein paar jahren kauften sie
tardelli und wurden so eines der größten
militär unternehmen der welt das ist das
neue wachstum das wir in colorado
springs beobachten
[Musik]
von jedem dollar den steuerzahler an die
usa zahlen gehen 50 cent an das pentagon
und finanzieren die kriege der
vergangenheit gegenwart und zukunft
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wir werden zu einer krieger kultur
umgewandelt
[Musik]
fast eine dreiviertel million
erstaunlicher menschen die ihnen ihren
land sie sind alle überzeugt sie haben
den besten job der welt
[Musik]
es ist schon cool abend seinen kindern
zu erzielen man fliege satelliten in
geostationäre umlaufbahn
dass man mit dem stärksten radar der
welt unseren himmel überwacht und mit
teleskopen für die sicherheit des landes
sorgen
dafür zu sorgen dass die atomraketen
jederzeit zum schutz des landes
einsatzbereit sind
das ist doch eine coole branche
wer detail der us airforce
an uns kommt keiner ran
[Musik]
das ist unser großes labor hier drüben
arbeiten kadetten im ersten jahr an
komponenten unserer falken fall
satelliten
die wir derzeit entwerfen und auf der
körper und air force base in new mexico
testen werden
luft und raumfahrt faszinieren mich
schon seit ich klein war
nach der highschool suchte ich nach
einem college die airforce schien eine
coole möglichkeit zu sein da ich
weltraumtechnologie und satelliten
design studieren konnte die air force
academy war die natürliche wahl
[Musik]
das hier ist die star academy der air
force auf der körper und air force base
die arbeiten schüler mit einer software
und gestalten eine raumstation
es würden sie sie verkaufen oder
bewerben wollen
man hört aus dem ganzen land geschichten
die kinder in den schulen schon in
jungen jahren die indoktrination dieser
krieger kultur und der
weltraumtechnologie erfahren
jedes jahr lernen 50.000 schüler auf
militärbasen in den ganzen usa
weltraumtechnologie kennen
das pentagon plant langfristig
generationen von jugendlichen in
subventionierte luft und raumfahrt
berufe zu bringen
es ist uns sehr wichtig dass schüler
wissenschaften technologie und
mathematik kennenlernen unsere
mitarbeiter werden immer älter also
müssen wir für nachwuchs sorgen damit
unsere aktuellen wissenschaftler
irgendwann ersetzt werden können
[Musik]
ich sage es gibt keinen besseren
zeitpunkt als jetzt um uns für eine
zukünftige herausragende
führungsposition einzusetzen das ist die
aufgabe unserer nächsten generation wir
sind bereit für die gegenwart mit ihrer
hilfe und der unserer industriepartner
werden wir auch für die zukunft bereit
sein vielen dank
[Applaus]
[Musik]
dem pentagon zufolge ist die verlagerung
des wettrüstens im all das größte
industrie projekt in der geschichte der
erde
sie gehen kein risiko ein es muss einen
feind geben
die bevölkerung muss angst haben jemand
würde mit atomwaffen angreifen und wir
bräuchten raketenabwehr um uns zu
beschützen
nordkorea
moment was ist mit der bedrohung chinas
hat china nicht auch gezeigt dass sie
wie die usa satelliten in der umlaufbahn
zerstören können streben sie nicht auch
nach der vorherrschaft im all
die bedrohung im all ist ein
elektronisches pearl harbor die usa sind
das einzige ziel
es gibt manche die die bedrohung chinas
überzogen darstellen und sagen sie stehe
unmittelbar bevor ein gewaltiger
präventivschlag auf us systeme im all
und dem pazifik das sogenannte space
pearl harbor sie berufen sich oft auf
sensationsgierigen zeitungen und
boulevard blätter die nicht allzu
verlässlich sind
zb die geschichte von parasiten
satelliten ein boulevard-blatt aus
hongkong veröffentlichte informationen
von einer chinesischen webseite
was es in einem bericht des pentagon an
den kongress schaffte
niemand versuchte je zu ermitteln ob die
chinesische webseite überhaupt eine
glaubwürdige quelle war
er stellte sich heraus dass die
informationen einfach auf einer
persönlichen website in einem privaten
blog standen und nur erfunden waren
darüber hinaus waren auf der webseite
viele fotos halbnackter frauen und
reißerische bilder von geheimen
waffensystemen
eindeutig keine glaubwürdige
informationsquelle
[Musik]
sie scherten sich nicht darum die
informationen zurück zu verfolgen was
wir in etwa sechs stunden schafften
seit drei jahren versucht das pentagon
china als den neuen schwarzen mann
darzustellen und mit seinem satelliten
abwehr test spielte china ihnen dabei
auch noch direkt in die hände
[Musik]
ich war zu der zeit gerade auf einer
konferenz in colorado springs die
anwesenden offiziere verließen den raum
um den test live zu verfolgen
sie beobachteten den chinesischen
satelliten abwehrte
wir wissen über jeden raketenstart ins
all bescheid
unsere aufklärungssatelliten entdecken
sie alle
wir haben den chinesischen test entdeckt
und auch die zwei vorangegangenen
chinesischen tests die scheiterten
wir wissen bescheid es ist sehr schwer
weltraum tests zu verstecken sie gehören
zu den offensichtlichsten waffentests
überhaupt
was bezweckt china mit dieser
demonstration
es ist ganz einfach
es sollte eine warnung sein und eine
warnung muss von der anderen seite
wahrgenommen werden
china sagt er also
er wollte das all beherrschen dann müsst
ihr an uns vorbei
[Musik]
china wollte der welt den militärischen
machtanspruch der usa im alt zeigen
zugleich warnten sie davor dass china
sich dem entgegenstellen würde und in
der lage und willens seien amerikanische
waffen im all zu zerstören
wir wollen eine zukunft vermeiden
in der die erde von einer schicht aus
waffen umgeben ist
die die menschheit nur noch angreifbarer
machen würde als sie schon heute ist
china gab einen vorgeschmack des
tödlichen wettstreits die in eine
amerikanische bewaffnung des alls
auslösen würde wie nahe sind wir dem
schon
das us militär entwickelte etwas das die
airforce prompt global strike nennt
aktuell bedeutet das dass wir überall in
30 minuten einen atomschlag ausführen
könnten
der schwebt etwas beispielsweise
konventionelle angriffe auf chinesische
satelliten abwehr anlagen innerhalb von
minuten beinhaltet
dafür werden verschiedene konzepte
erforscht
eines war ein fluggerät in der
umlaufbahn dass dort viel schneller
manövrieren und waffen einsetzen kann
als es aktuell möglich ist
ein anderes wäre ein satellit der
mit raketen aus dem all ziele in fünf
bis zehn minuten treffen könnte
anstatt der aktuellen 30 minuten
die rede ist von einem satelliten system
namens stadt gottes das mit schweren
wolfram stäben aus dem als schutzbunker
auf der erde aufbrechen kann
das wird tatsächlich entwickelt
die forschung an diesen waffen hat schon
milliarden verschlungen und sonys
weapons einige davon sind beinahe schon
test bereit
bei einem orbitalen einsatz könnten
global strike systeme 100 ziele
gleichzeitig mit über 11.000 kilometern
pro stunde angreifen sie wären keine
massenvernichtungswaffen im sinne der un
regelung auch wenn ein staat gottes eine
ähnliche energie freisetzen würde wie
eine atombombe
satelliten können ziele mit
bildaufnahmen erfassen mit militärischen
entscheidungsträgern
kommunizieren und dann eine bombe leiten
so dass das ziel mit einem schlag
zerstört wird
wäre es ein so großer unterschied ein
geschoss direkt aus dem all zu starten
das ergebnis ist dasselbe auch für die
person am anderen ende
[Musik]
[Applaus]
im hochtechnologiebereich gibt es das
konzept des normalen unfalls dass die
fehler beschreibt die in jedem komplexen
system unweigerlich auftreten werden
jeder der einen computer hat kennt
normale unfälle denn ab und zu stürzt
das system aus unerklärlichen gründen
einfach ab bei noch komplizierteren
systemen ist das unausweichlich
bei all unserer technologie wissen wir
ganz genau dass wir niemals sicher sein
können dass unsere intelligenten bomben
das richtige ziel treffen
allein schon afghanistan und der irak
zeigen uns deutlich dass das ein
irrglaube ist
sie treffen zivilisten nicht irakische
armee basel was sie tun ist falsch
wie viel schlimmer wäre die chance das
falsche ziel oder gar uns selbst vom all
aus zu treffen
das können wir uns unmöglich ausrechnen
zumindest eine einzelne waffe könnte
eine fehlfunktion haben und in new york
oder sonst wo landen
wenn wir die augen vor dieser realität
verschließen werden wir zum opfer
unserer eigenen technologie
[Musik]
den rest der welt ist natürlich bewusst
dass die usa planen den weltraum zu
bewaffnen darum gibt es bestrebungen den
un weltraum vertrag zu erneuern
er verbietet nur
massenvernichtungswaffen im all es gab
anstrengungen ihn zu erneuern und zu
stärken
die usa blockieren das jedes jahr
[Musik]
es steht immer 160 zu 1 170 2 1 nur die
vereinigten staaten sperren sich hierbei
wir stehen in dieser frage allein da
es wäre wirklich schön wenn die
bewaffnung des alls verhindert würde
nicht weil es einen so großen aufschrei
dagegen gibt wobei das auch interessant
wäre sondern weil niemand einschließlich
unserem land das nötige geld dafür mehr
hat
aber da die usa immer noch ein
militärbudget von über 500 milliarden
dollar unterhalten würde ich nicht
darauf zählen dass das passiert
es ist wirklich irrsinnig
wir geben hunderte milliarden für die
entwicklung der weltraum kontrolle aus
obwohl ein abkommen das obsolet machen
würde
würden wir so einen vertrag aushandeln
wollen und die federführung übernehmen
könnten wir so etwas eher wirken
es wäre sehr schwer aber
möglich
wie könnte ein abkommen alle satelliten
abwehrwaffen verbieten ein laser am
boden eine einfache rakete und viele
systeme im orbit können satelliten
zerstören kann ein vertrag garantieren
dass kilwi klos nur raketen und keine
satelliten oder eintreffenden objekte
ins visier nehmen gegner eines neuen
abkommens halten solche versprechen für
unhaltbar und verspätet
die bewaffnung des alls fand vor langer
zeit stand
die vorstellung es wäre eine saubere
umgebung die wir nur in ruhe lassen
müssen damit alles gut würde ist unsinn
es wäre töricht anzunehmen wir könnten
den geist zurück in die flasche stopfen
wir brauchen ein un abkommen aber das
reicht nicht und ist nur der erste
schritt
schritt zwei ist die akzeptanz dass das
all bereits militarisiert wurde und es
dort militärische netzwerke gibt von
denen viele btps auch nützlich sind wir
sollten ein abkommen aushandeln durch
dass diese militärischen netzwerke nur
noch für multilaterale zwecke dienen
ich bezweifle dass das realistisch ist
aber ich gebe die hoffnung nicht auf
frau bringen
[Applaus]
ich werde die verschwendung dutzende
milliarden dollar für unerprobte
raketenabwehrsysteme unterbinden ich
werde dass allen nicht bewaffnen
dienen die die bewaffnung des alls
fürchten gehabt die wahl barack obamas
hoffnung direkt nach seinem amtsantritt
verkündete das weiße haus man würde sich
für ein weltweites verbot von waffen
einsetzen die militärische und
kommerzielle satelliten angreifen können
die jahrzehnte lang gepflegte aufrüstung
des alls zu verändern erwies sich jedoch
als schwierig
[Musik]
obamas verteidigungsetat für 2010
enthielt fast eine milliarde dollar für
raum krieg systeme
es enthielt das neue programm offensiv
counter space dessen ziele das pentagon
wie folgt definiert
offensive maßnahmen zur störung
verweigerung zersetzung oder zerstörung
aller feindlichen raumfahrt fähigkeiten
[Musik]
die geschichte zeigt dass länder nicht
freiwillig abrüsten
sie werden entweder besiegt
oder sie verändern die beschaffung die
konstruktion und den einsatz ihrer
waffen ein wenig
keine supermacht sagt sich jedoch
es wäre schon schön wenn wir schwächer
werden das passiert nicht
die vorherrschaft im all zu erlangen
ohne anzugreifen ist schwierig
wenn wir die vorherrschaft wollen müssen
wir wohl oder übel angreifen
wenn wir allerdings ein trümmerfeld im
all erzeugen behindert das auch uns
selbst und setzt eine kettenreaktion in
gang ist die erde von einer schrott
wolke umgeben ist
etwa 600.000 bruchstücke rasen durch das
als zehnmal so schnell wie eine gewähr
kunde
all diese objekte sind 22 1500 kilometer
pro stunde schnell selbst ein erbsen
großes objekt ist bei der
geschwindigkeit zerstörerischer als eine
kanonenkugel
das problem des weltraumschrotts ist
bereits so groß dass die nasa davon
ausgeht dass selbst wenn nichts mehr ins
all geschossen wird da jeder staat
zumindest kleine trümmer hinterlässt
in 50 jahren bestimmte umlaufbahnen
durch den müll unbrauchbar werden
dass es bereits da ist wird dann in mehr
und mehr splitter zerlegt
[Musik]
die zerstörung eines satelliten setzt
eine wolke an trümmern frei die umgebung
des planeten verseucht und alles bedroht
was sich in seiner umlaufbahn befindet
es geht darum dass die erzeugung dieser
trümmer eine extrem schlechte
angelegenheit ist
wir können sie schließlich nicht wieder
entfernen
wenn man ins all aufbrechen und die
zerstörung anderer satelliten übt
entsteht so viel schrott dass es
irgendwann unmöglich wird eine rakete
von der erde aus zu starten
es wäre wie ein minenfeld um den
planeten die rakete könnte nicht
entkommen da der ganze weltraumschrott
sie zerstören würde
wir müssen das als teil der umwelt
begreifen
es wurden hunderte milliarden dollar in
die friedliche nutzung des weltalls
investiert
wettersatelliten
gps
forschungssatelliten
das gesamte kommunikationsnetz der welt
basiert außerdem
diese unglaublichen investitionen der
usa der europäischen union kanadas und
anderer staaten sind alle in gefahr wenn
wir waffen ins all schaffen
wie würde der wegfall von satelliten die
welt verändern tag 1 615
kommunikationssatelliten über den usa
fallen aus das gps bricht zusammen
die atomuhren der gps-satelliten können
sich nicht koordinieren
die infrastruktur synchronisation bricht
zusammen
350 millionen handys fallen aus hunderte
millionen internet- verbindungen ebenso
kartenzahlungen und konnten weltweit
sind eingefroren ganze branchen
verlieren milliarden es kommt zum crash
nachrichtendienste brechen zusammen
städte die gps zum verkehrsmanagement
nutzen verfallen ins chaos
stromnetze verlieren die
synchronisierung in weiten teilen der
welt fällt der strom aus
die küstenwache empfängt keine notrufe
mehr
dutzende flugzeuge verschwinden
fluglotsen geraten in panik weltweit
fallen flüge aus oder werden
zurückgerufen des mitternacht kommt es
zu unzähligen unfällen im straßen-
schienen- und flugverkehr
bislang konnten wir eine solche
katastrophe vermeiden
ein raum krieg würde jedoch satelliten
zerstören deren schrott das system auf
das wir uns verlassen
unwiederbringlich vernichtet wird
6 uhr 25 in unserer sondersendung zur
weltweiten konferenz geht es um die
bewaffnung des weltalls es könnte bald
schon so sein dass die usa das also
stark beherrschen das ein besseres nun
möglich wäre das hat es nicht für
möglich der technologische fortschritt
wird dazu führen dass wir trotz
jeglichem vorsprung irgendwann wieder
herausgefordert werden
es ist wie nach dem zweiten weltkrieg
als außer uns niemand atombomben hatte
wir dachten dieses
alleinstellungsmerkmal würde uns die
weltherrschaft sichern
es hat nicht lange gehalten die sowjets
hatten atombomben china insel
auch im weltraum ist die idee dass wir
dort als einzige waffen positionieren
und der könig des weltalls werden
könnten
tragisch
du monde trouw alle halten die
bewaffnung des weltalls für gefährlich
sie würde andere länder animieren
ebenfalls weltraum waffen zu entwickeln
muss bastian in ihr indien hat die
entwicklung eigener satelliten
abwehrwaffen in der werbung gezogen
wenn sie es tun wird auch pakistan nicht
zögern
in israel wird auch darüber diskutiert
nur wenige länder würden sich der
vorherrschaft der usa finden einige
würden sie stürzen andere zumindest
ihren teil sichern wollen feinde würden
voranpreschen und instabile staaten mit
sich reißen die europäische union stemmt
sich gegen die bewaffnung des aber wie
lange noch
wenn die usa weiterhin militärische
satelliten und weltraum waffen
entwickeln werden wir möglichkeiten
finden müssen uns vor der amerikanischen
bedrohung und den resultierenden
wettrüsten zu schützen eine eventuelle
koch so sachen
russland würde sich einschalten und
versuchen alle us waffen in der
umlaufbahn zu zerstören
wenn die usa abwehrsysteme gegen
ballistische raketen im all
positionieren
wären auch abfangsysteme auf
militärischen raumstationen denkbar
sie würden dann unweigerlich das
staatsgebiet russlands oder chinas
überfliegen
russland würde das niemals akzeptieren
kann
[Musik]
die potenziellen opfer sagen da nicht
hier bitte schneide mir die kehle durch
sie würden wissen dass sie potenzielle
ziele sind und gegen die weltraum waffen
der usa vollkommen wertlos werden wenn
sie sie nicht zerstören oder eigene
abwehr oder abschreckungsmaßnahmen
entwickeln wir kennen die
abschreckungsmaßnahmen
atomwaffen sind eine terror ist eine
andere
darum führt aggressiver militarismus zu
mehr terrorismus
[Musik]
der krieg der sterne ist keine fantasie
mehr sondern wirklichkeit
eine solche politik führt natürlich zu
einem wettring
dieses dominanz gefahren befördert die
verbreitung verheerender waffen
russland hält die folgen der bewaffnung
des alls für die internationale gemeinde
für unvorhersehbare
könnte ein neues atom zeitalter
herbeiführen
[Musik]
während des kalten krieges befürchtete
die menschheit die erde könnte in eine
reihe grelle blitze zu einem trostlosen
friedhof werden
[Musik]
nach wie vor sind tausende atomwaffen
weltweit jederzeit einsatzbereit die
bewaffnung des als könnte der funken im
pulverfass sein
die angst davor dass waffen im weltall
positioniert oder von dort abgefeuert
werden
könnte durch unfälle menschliche fehler
bloße absicht oder terroristisches
eingreifen zum abschluss von bis zu 9000
wasserstoffbomben für die eine kleine
eiszeit auslösen und fast alles leben
auf der erde auslöschen wollen
wir stehen vor dem abgrund nuklearer
vernichtung
wenn wir das all bewaffnen können wir
uns von unserer welt verabschieden die
überlebenschancen sind gering
[Musik]
wird einem sein ganzes leben lang wieder
und wieder gesagt amerika seien
besonders außergewöhnliches land
glaubt man es ehrlich
[Applaus]
ich war in der air france ein junger
republikaner unter nixon
und wuchs jenseits des stacheldrahts auf
militärbasen auf
alles was ich lernte war militarismus
und eine konservative weltanschauung
[Applaus]
jetzt habe ich aber begriffen dass
amerikas handeln nicht der verteidigung
dient sondern dem angriff
eine aggressive militärdoktrin die
kontrolle und dominanz nächste
ich habe eine vollständige verwandlung
durchgemacht alle meine überzeugungen
änderten sich das jedoch immer gleich
blieb war mein gutes herz auch als
konservativer junge anhänger des
militärs war mein herz am rechten fleck
das gilt für viele beim militär ihr herz
ist am rechten fleck sie tun das was sie
für das richtige halten um ihr land zu
schützen
es wird situationen geben die ihre
innere führung auf die probe stellen ob
sie den schweren oder den einfachen weg
wählen den falschen oder den richtigen
die meisten menschen wollen ihr herz am
rechten fleck haben ein denkanstoß wird
sie nicht über nacht verändern das war
bei mir genauso es dauerte eine weile
bis ich mich hinter den toren der
militärbasis ändern konnte man muss nur
den anstoß geben
die entschlossenheit immer den richtigen
weg zu wählen auch wenn es der schwere
ist nennt man charakter
man muss in allen bereichen seines
lebens im privaten wie im berufsleben
steht seinen überzeugungen treu bleiben
und integrität wagen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
wir leben in einer sehr gefährlichen ära
und es wird viel zu wenig darauf
hingewiesen
viele kommen gerade so tag für tag über
die runden und
versuchen den anbetracht all des
wahnsinns nicht verrückt zu werden
wenn man ihnen sagt dass es noch viel
schlimmer sei als sie glauben
wollen sie das nicht hören wir müssen
sie dennoch darauf aufmerksam machen was
tatsächlich passiert das ist keine
einfache aufgabe
wir sollten ausnahmsweise mal etwas
schlimmes verhindern bevor es geschieht
üblicherweise versuchen wir waffen
zurückzuholen die bereits eingesetzt
wurden wie unsere atomwaffen wir haben
die historische chance pro aktiv zu sein
und ein neues wettrüsten zu verhindern
bevor es wirklich anfängt
das macht diesen moment zu bedeuten
die diskussion über die bewaffnung des
ice ist die wichtigste debatte des
nächsten jahrhunderts
und wir stehen in vielen ländern kurz
davor zu entscheiden welchen pfad wie
einschlagen sollen
[Applaus]
herzlichen glückwunsch gott schütze sie
und die vereinigten staaten
herr wir bieten dafür die ich auf
unserem weg in der welt im wahren geist
zu verehren
könnten wir die moralisch bessere
position wählen oder sind wir dazu
verdammt uns militärisch besser
aufstellen zu wollen
viele staaten sträuben sich dagegen
unter der herrschaft eines einzelnen
weltweiten frieden einzuläuten
können die usa führen anstatt herrschaft
anzustreben
können die vereinigten staaten ein
staatenbündnis anstatt der pax americana
zu einer packs universales führen einem
frieden für die ganze welt
in christi namen beten wir armen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
welche art frieden wollen hier
nicht die pax americana der welt durch
amerikanische waffen aufgezwungen
sondern
echten frieden nicht
für das leben auf der welt lebenswert
macht
frieden nicht nur für amerikaner sondern
für alle männer und frauen nicht nur in
unserer zeit sondern für alle zeit
[Musik]